キュアぬーんぬーんっ
ブーブーますうードゥ
アドぽいなぁ
ぽいな
これ誰のこれらの顔が一番の問題だと思うんですよ
ブサイクすぎでしょ
ああっやばい
ん
小栗が見えるっ
おおぉもーん
大規模いたいぞ
いやー
やばいん
だってねぇぺっぺっ家がめっちゃ抜けるんですけど今回はこちらのゴリラを使って
まあ後半よねこれが襲撃ドッキリをしようと思いますって言っわけで夏も僕はドッキリ
を仕掛けるんねちょっと今回は
沢民が雑っ記を読んで
撮影をしていますでタッグミットターゲットがその動画を撮っている時に後ろから俺が
ゴリラの格好して茂みからガーンである漏れで結構撮影しに行く場所が動物園の近くな
んで
越前にターゲットに打っローブ前回のゴリラーがたそうした様みたいなことを言っとい
ていたんけどこれから脱走していると思っています
一発ねっ
あいつの頭の中を1回真っ白にしてみたいんでね
お腹はないと思うけど
ブーブー
はい11台カメラの雪が終わったんでゴリラに着替えます
べさっき消えず分に撮ってると思ったんですけど首が見えるから首だけ黒いテープで次
に黒くしておきます
よしまあこんなもんでいいでしょよしちょっとご覧に違います
あっ2杯一応今連絡が来てもうすぐ来るんでちょっと車で待機してます
ブーバーンよはいじゃあ
もうたが2人が包んで僕はもう過ぎ3-0に隠れます地獄を見せてやるぜねこれででき
たぽんぽこいいからね
隠れますじゃあまた2 tone
問題等の動物園最近脱走あったらしくてああ
そうだぞ
rank はせ後日なんけど
ええええじゃああっ
待ってカメラますよ
じゃあありますか
今日はベンチャー撮影と木刀バー先と3人でバイク持ってるんで強圧とバイキンについ
ての動画をよりこれこっちで載ってたのがそんななかったんだよなるほどへ持ち帰って
から結構間ずっとするなぁ
から食べスコッチっもうそんなにかかってなかったんですよあの最初なろう
の背よりだろぐらいまで
ねー
re ん
んおおおおおお
をキャスト
時対戦ファーよっさん
キャットタワー
はっんのなちゅ伺った絵は今日は角呼び割っては軍4ドレスと
そういう広場エアー除去1さん俺のキャッシュだ
hey
re
ここはいえこんなビックリしたもん全部クルスター
うそ